bear - Player 01KA8MYER1VVZ49VW6AFBPWJ3J:Thank you for calling Portugal.
transcript:1
bear - Player 01KA8MYER1VVZ49VW6AFBPWJ3J:To help us direct your call to the right person. Please select from one of the following options.
transcript:2
bear - Player 01KA8MYER1VVZ49VW6AFBPWJ3J:If you're looking to rent or letter property,
transcript:3
bear - Player 01KA8MYER1VVZ49VW6AFBPWJ3J:please press one.
transcript:4
bear - Player 01KA8MYER1VVZ49VW6AFBPWJ3J:For sales, press two.
transcript:5
bear - Player 01KA8MYER1VVZ49VW6AFBPWJ3J:And if you're a landlord or tenant with us already,
transcript:6
bear - Player 01KA8MYER1VVZ49VW6AFBPWJ3J:please press three for property management.
transcript:7
bear - Player 01KA8MYER1VVZ49VW6AFBPWJ3J:Please note that calls may be recorded for training and quality purposes.
transcript:8
bear - Player 01KA8MYF1JHQGJSMGA8WF0XP0A:Pay to spot.
transcript:9
bear - Player 01KA8MYER1VVZ49VW6AFBPWJ3J:Paid it was spot.
transcript:10
bear - Player 01KA8MYF1JHQGJSMGA8WF0XP0A:Yeah.
transcript:11
bear - Player 01KA8MYF1JHQGJSMGA8WF0XP0A:Stop
transcript:12
bear - Player 01KA8MYF1JHQGJSMGA8WF0XP0A:I
transcript:13
bear - Player 01KA8MYF1JHQGJSMGA8WF0XP0A:Bye.